now to kanye's friend and collaborator
dr dre who's facing his own crisis
[Music]
the 55 year old music mogul was rushed
to l.a cedar sinai hospital after
reportedly suffering a brain aneurysm he
currently appears to be in stable
condition
dre took to instagram last night saying
quote i'm doing great
and getting excellent care from my
medical team i will be out of the
hospital and back home
[Music]
while soon the hospital four people were
apprehended trying to break into dr
dre's home
but back to dre's hospitalization i
asked doctors host dr
ian smith about his prognosis there are
two types of brain aneurysms when a
brain aneurysm
ruptures it can of course be deadly very
quickly based on the reporting
i'm not his doctor the fact that they're
saying that he's speaking right now and
that he's saying he's going home soon
it's very unlikely
that he had a ruptured brain aneurysm
and what about the role stress played in
all this
dre is in the midst of a very
contentious estimated
820 million divorce from wife of 24
years nicole young
it really is a physical issue either
someone has long-standing high blood
pressure
they may have a family history of
aneurysm so it's not just because i'm
stressed out
and all of a sudden i have a brain bleed
it just doesn't work that way
we know he is a huge weight lifter could
that be a problem or an issue you know
kevin that is the first thing i thought
about we say stay away from lifting
heavy objects because
that could cause a rupture
you